what we got to do well today we're going
to change it
I forgot you know there's a lot of
people knowing divided wasn't obvious
enough for me even little thoughts going
around to her Muslims on a specific day
and we're out today to speak for the
British public and wasn't asked him how
they filled up for the jump potatoes
beans whoa wait
I just brushed into that poor lamppost
man I just pushed into the lamppost
[Music]
your reaction to this no there's the
score point how to punish a loser
once you take them back with friends of
muscles yeah it is if you pull off a
woman to jump off you get 25 points yeah
well what do you think triggers people
to do such things happy be with
ignorance yeah so what'd you do today do
some raise awareness about it let's talk
about and just just a shot at the
general British probably gonna feel like
did you feel a bit like you know who
says who didn't to come out what would
you like now I'm going out nobody's
something me having a waffle
[Music]
so what if it is this letter was sent
out to a couple of people and obviously
the score point you know if you abuse
oppose them again ten points if you be
able to them up you get a hundred points
I don't really do it in points I would
have give a gift card at least as well I
find that really objectionable really
maybe you could just read that
[Music]
punished
third of April to first night so
basically today I've gotta admit that is
an absolute joke it was it yeah
leading a half five years Wow I'm not
the best
I'm just practicing you know I mean I'm
trying to get on the streets how do you
feel as a Muslim that sickens that you
heard my first mean you know you know
worse in my language that's yeah it's
disgusting
yeah it's sad
yeah
ten points but
50 points for acid in the yes barely
gets completely awful like I think that
nobody should get punished
are you ready for this okay
basically the business that's around
four points about business
why didn't we do it don't want anybody
would do that so any book you have
Muslim friends why do you think people I
love like I believe they're really nice
people in general it's just a few you
know a few bad people three friends yeah
change the minds change everything don't
drink before he's like a gangster so
glad you saw for yourself as we hit the
streets of London and saw the reaction
of the general public and how disgusted
they were for this letter I want to
share a few things with you not you I'm
gonna make this not very long shala
number one at the start the video as you
saw guru of car every day research a
cloud to protect you from any evilness
speed from the jinkind for the mankind
yeah
that's first thing first that we should
always keep in mind I had to cross her I
had to go see surah Naas for a class and
sort of phallic make sure you recite
them all the time wherever you are
whatever you doing another thing I want
to mention is when I see these kind of
things off you know hurting and
individual you know Moses what if it
maybe what comes to my mind is about the
Prophet peace be upon him and answered
and the muhajireen what they went
through
now in many places in the Quran our
sponsor dimensions what the private
piece you when Anna's complain
went to in surah Anfal verse 30 it talks
about with Alice one words fine what
Allah says and remember o Muhammad when
those the pagans plotted against you to
restrain you or kill you or a bit in
victory from that cup but they planned
and on the plan that needs the best of
planners this have seen routed to seven
even caffeine if I'm not mistaken is
that they're talking about the time
where the tribes came together and he
wanted to kill the Prophet peace be upon
it and allowed miraculously saved him
when we go to surah surah in R and verse
195 I must want to assess so those who
emigrated or evicted from their homes
over heart in my course or were killed
and which I love will surely move from
their misdeeds and I do it and will
surely admit them to Gardens beneath
which rivers flow when we go to same
chapter surah Imran verse 1 to 3 123
Allah had helped you at butter his
brother is when the pagans were coming
to attack the Muslims when you were
helpless with little force then fear
Allah and also when we go to surah
bruges almost want Allah said when they
said verse 6 to 8 Allah says when they
sat by it and were witness to what they
were doing to the believers the Muslims
and they took not vengeance on them but
for no other reason because they
believed in Allah and His Messenger and
lastly when we go to surah Tauba verse
13 we can see the allah says would you
not defend yourself against those who
broke their oath and determined to
export the messenger and they had begun
to attack you first and the Prophet
manatees Rubin and his companions they
had many treaties with different people
and they were constantly attacked the
battle of hunayn
maybe the Battle of Tabuk be it the
Battle of Badr the battle over the
Battle of the trench you could clearly
see that the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and what they went through and
subhanAllah
what we go for today means nothing it
means nothing when certain companies
came and complained to the prophet
muhammed sallalahu they was seldom that
the struggle is too much and the Prophet
kind of reviewed them and said you know
what previous nations with him their
skins were ripped off so brothers and
sisters we should be grateful
and inaudible I mean that we live in a
country that enables and allow us allows
us to practice our faith how we want
when we want and we should be grateful
to that you know and appreciate that and
appreciate that
you don't chance a and appreciate that
hunting in love and take advantage of
this will unser
the prophet went through madnesses they
were killed and tortured and this to
print will lie today was for everything
we've got everything and we stood on
pray so it's a reminder to you guys
everyone is that these days whatever it
may be
be cautious be careful but do not take
them seriously and appreciate appreciate
what the companions went through to what
we saw that we can have what we have
today and let's take full advantage of
worship in our Lord and our Lord alone
you are only worship and you alone we
ask for help turn to allah subhanaw
taala thank you very much hope you guys
enjoyed it share with your friends our
family but bye